>>Male Presenter: Alright everyone, thanks
for coming to another @Google event. It is
my pleasure to introduce to you today P.J.
Simmons, he’s a good friend of mine. He
has worked for over fifteen years to connect
sustainability issues to public foreign policy
and business affairs. Ah, I’ve got a brief
edited list of things he's done, bear with
me. He is the founder and co-founder and chairman
of the Corporate Eco Forum. The members of
this forum are basically the "who’s who"
of the global economy. Google is a member
of the forum. He served as a research assistant
on International Environmental affairs at
the National Security Council. He founded
the Woodrow Wilson Center's Environmental
Change and Security Program. He founded and
edited Washington DC's first Consumer Guide
to Environmentally Friendly Businesses. He
served twice as the Clinton Global Initiative
Deputy Chair for Energy and Climate Change.
He directed the first Clinton Global Initiative
University Climate Program. P.J. also, he
received his BA in Political Science from
Tufts and his MA from Johns Hopkins. He was
a Fulbright scholar to the former Yugoslavia
and he holds of Certificate in Conservation
Biology from Columbia University. Outside
of that and the things I left off here, P.J.
has done nothing else. [laughs]. He is also
the co-author of the book Green to Gold Business
Playbook and that is what he is here to talk
to us about today. So, take it away P.J.
>> P.J. Simmons: Thanks so much, Jason. Good
afternoon everybody. When Google first invited
me to come here, and I am so grateful to be
here, I instantly said “yes”. Of course
as Jason mentioned Google is a member of the
Corporate Eco Forum. I know the company well
and the company is actually been a real leader
in the space of sustainability innovation.
Um, but you know I actually subscribe to the
email that says when there is new Google talks
and one of the first things that I wanted
to do was check out who had done recent Google
talks and so of course I saw Tina Fey and
Mario Batali and the two winners of the American
Idol [chuckles] and then some guy that was
talking about men’s sexual health and I
thought “Well, my work is cut out for me”.
Tough acts to follow but I am going to try
to do my best to impart some knowledge on
you and I really appreciate you coming out
today.
Let me just start by giving an introduction
to this book and where it came about. Back
in 2006, a book called Green to Gold that
my co-author Dan Esty wrote with Andrew Winston
and at the time it really made a big impact
because it really made a compelling case for
why companies ought to view environmental
issues and sustainability issues beyond the
realm of corporate social responsibility and
as philanthropic issues and really see them
as core strategic issues for the future of
their businesses. And it was the book of the
meeting at Davos, the World Economic Summit
in 2006. It really changed a lot of minds
and it really was this sort of "why" . And
Dan Esty called me a couple of years ago and
knowing that I had been working with a lot
of Fortune 500 companies and large global
companies in the Corporate Eco Forum to ask
if I would be interested in working on the
companion book the how to Green to Gold. And
that is the origin of the play book. We wanted
to create something that was really practical
that really helped people across a range of
different business functions so not just the
people with sustainability in their titles
and the environmental green team folks, but
people who do information technology for companies,
people that do buildings and facilities, supply
chain executives and so forth. A quick word
about the organization that Jason mentioned
that Google is part of, and I should say by
the way that Jason mentioned I was deputy
chair of the Clinton Global Initiative for
a couple of years on Energy and Climate change.
My co-deputy Michael Terrell is actually a
Googler based in California and was one of
my favorite colleagues to work with. The basic
idea of the Corporate Eco Forum, which we
set up in 2008, is to create a safe space
for their Senior Executives, again not just
the folks with the Environmental title but
people that are doing all sorts of different
things to drive successful business within
companies to kind of shut the door and sort
of create a safe space for them to exchange
their war stories and their success stories
in trying to make Green work for their companies
in a way that is profitable and lead to hard
business results. The [pause] and it has been
a really fabulous learning experience for
me and was a big part of the inputs that went
into this book. But I want to sort of flash
back for a few years. Many of you may have
seen this ad on TV, this 30 second ad spot
by IBM where there was this skeptical CFO
type, Chief Financial Officer, sitting behind
a desk and this woman comes in, the commercial
was shot in black and white in the first part.
She is saying that this is a case for why
the company ought to invest in some energy
efficiency measures. And the guy is really
skeptical and basically says this is going
to be great for the tree huggers, I get it,
it is really a nice thing that we want to
do this but really from a business perspective
why should I sign this. And she then goes
through all of the costs savings and the millions
of dollars that the company is going to save
if they do it and all of a sudden it shifts
into color sort of like Dorothy landing in
Oz and the birds start signing and the music
starts playing [chuckles lightly] and he says
“where do I sign”. The remarkable thing
is since the book came out and since that
commercial came out there are so many examples
of companies that have actually had that experience
where somebody has gone into a skeptical CEO
or CFO office and made a case for investing
in something that might be a higher upfront
cost but would generate some really serious
payback in lots of different ways and because
of all that anecdotal evidence and because
so many people are seeing that from their
peers it has lead to a lot of people jumping
on the band wagon. And that really, again,
is what the book is all about is to showcase
a lot of those case stories and really go
through the benefits of how Green creates
business value. The Green to Gold framework
which, back in the first book, outlined four
key benefits that we build on in this book.
The first of the four benefits is Cutting
Costs and this is where most companies start
on their Green Journey. This is the most well
understood, it’s the most easiest to justify
to financial types and get budget for. The
idea is that Green in the new lean, if you
use a Green lens and Green principles you
are going to find new forms of waste , hidden
forms of waste that are costing precious time
and resources that are taking money away from
their profits. And you know one of the biggest
areas here focuses energy waste but we are
also talking about other operational costs
and inefficiencies. The result of water waste,
scrap waste, chemical waste and all sorts
of other things that lead to regulatory burdens
and all sorts of other expenses. The second
big area is Reducing Risk and here we are
not just talking about sort of the mega risks
that we are all familiar with and we see on
the news, the BP spill in the Gulf of Mexico
or catastrophic chemical accidents. But we
are also talking about the kind of environmentally
related risks that creep up on companies and
that may not be on a lot of strategic planners’
minds but ought to be given the way that trends
are shaping up around the world. One of those
examples, if you are a company that is a beverage
company for example like Coco Cola that relies
heavily on water, it’s a key input for you.
The fact that world water resource, fresh
water resources, are becoming more scarce
is a big concern to you. Not only because
it’s a key input to your product but also
because you might get blamed and might get
a lot of the exposure for being part of perpetuating
the problem if you don’t fix it. And that
is one of the reasons why Coca Cola is one
of those companies that is actually investing
in Water Shed Restoration and Protection around
the world to create the system so that water
actually keeps getting generated. And there
are lots of other examples of that in the
IT realm. For example there is a lot of other
companies like Google that are using huge
amounts of energy because their information-intensive
and have a lot of data centers and a lot of
servers and so companies are thinking “what
about the price of energy? What happens when
carbon-based energy becomes more expensive?”
So what does it look like to invest in other
forms of energy that might not expose us to
so much of those changes? The third big area
is Growing Revenues and this is where is starts
getting really interesting and where we have
seen a sea of change in the last couple of
years in the way that big global companies
start thinking about their environment from
just this compliance thing to a cost reduction
thing to a risk reduction thing to actually
something that might really help drive innovation,
drive growth of their business, be a source
of future revenues and competitiveness. Dupont,
the chemical company, is an example of one
that actually set a 6 billion dollar revenue
goal by 2015 for products that are built around
sustainability. A lot of you are probably
familiar with the ads for Ecomagination by
GE. They have been so successful, that originally
started as a marketing initiative where the
company was already doing a lot of products
that were really good delivered a lot of environmental
reductions and benefits and the CEO, Jeff
Immelt sort of pulled people together and
said “How can we better communicate this
stuff? How do we package this in a way that
gets the message out there?” So they came
up with Ecomagination but that ended up being
so successful that it launched a whole new
wave of thinking within the company and a
new wave of innovation. The revenue goals
for 2012 for that company, for the Ecomagination
line are 25 billion dollars. Huge growth area
from where it was just a few years ago. And
Proctor and Gamble, a big consumer goods company
that you are all familiar with, makes detergents
and all sorts of household products, they
are now looking at a revenue goal by next
year of 50 billion dollars in sustainable
product innovations. That has to do with anything
from low compact laundry detergent that uses
less energy and less product, costs less to
ship to all sorts of different innovations
there.
And then the final area which is harder to
describe for a lot of people, harder for people
to buy into but it’s probably one of the
biggest when it goes to Environmental Sustainability
and it has to do with brand and intangibles.
And here we are talking about the benefits
that aren’t easily captured on traditional
financial statements and accounting statements
but they are the kinds of things that are
really important drivers of future earnings
and of share holder value and of stock price.
We are talking about brand equity, customer
satisfaction, customer loyalty, are people
going to stay with you are shift over to the
next big thing when someone else invents it.
License to operate around the world, reduced
operational burden and interference from regulators,
from NGOs; less Green Peace sort of demonstration
of what you are doing, less regulators breathing
down your back, stronger ability to attract
top talent and retain top talent and for a
company like Google that is absolutely enormous
and priceless. Stronger R and D and innovation
capacity within the company, how nimble, how
adaptive and how creative is the culture and
capable of actually responding and looking
at trends in the world, looking at customer’s
needs, looking at how things are changing
and adapting to that and innovating. It is,
a brief word about stock value, going back
to Coca Cola for a second. Twenty percent
of its market capitalization can be attributed
to its book value and it’s hard assets.
But eighty percent of the value is attributed
to intangibles, like how investors view the
strength of its brand; it’s exposure to
risks, its R and D capacity and so forth.
And there are companies that are smaller like
New Belgium Brewing Company which makes some
of my favorite beers, based in Colorado, that
have really experienced the people-related
benefits of going green. Their CEO is really
charged up about sustainability and you see
a bike in their actual logo. Their, they have
an employee retention rate of 95 percent and
their motivated workforce has really propelled
them to exceed the growth rate of a lot of
their competitors. The industry average is
about 80 percent; their growth rate has been
13½ percent. Another example of a much bigger
scale of total brand turnaround is WalMart.
This is a picture of Mike Duke addressing
earlier this year sustainability gather of
his company. That company if you flash back
to before Katrina, Hurricane Katrina, and
the tragedy there. It was getting hammered
by NGO and the public left and right for being
bad on social issues, being bad on environment
and so forth. And there was a kind of an “Ah-Ha”
moment when the company decided from a values
perspective to do the right thing with Katrina
and think about how it could actually help
make a big difference in alleviating suffering
and helping people. At that time the CEO Lee
Scott walked away and thought to himself and
with some urging from other colleagues thought
“What would it be like if WalMart was always
at it’s best like this?” And that plus
a lot of other personal transformations and
conversations with experts that WalMart had
lead to an imaging of a future where WalMart
actually would be loved by people and would
attract people that actually care about sustainability.
But it also started looking at it from a hard
business perspective of resources running
out, prices changing, of all these factors
and its license to operate all around the
world. And it started thinking how could it
change the way it does business and it’s
been a profound transformation. And if anybody
is actually interesting in learning more about
that there is great book called Force of Nature,
which I just read a few weeks ago. It really
is kind of a great behind the scenes story
about that transformation. Going back to this
IBM commercial, even though there is so much
exciting stuff that we talk about in the Playbook
that I’m part of with the Corporate Eco
Forum review that I learned about, the reality
is that the vast majority of people in business
still think like the CFO behind the desk.
They think of environment and sustainability
as a cost center. Something that is going
to be a pain in the neck, an add-on to everything
that they are already doing. And one of the
interesting indications of this, there was
a survey that a big company called Forrester
Research did at the end of last year, 2010
fourth quarter. And it asks something like
2600 company executives that had budget authority
“What are your top business priorities for
2011?” So you can see the top is growth,
company revenue is really important. Attracting
and retaining customers is one of those intangibles
but a really important priority. Efficiency,
lowering operating costs, improving quality
of products and processes. Innovation, again
intangible stuff but how do you improve your
ability to innovate as a company, how do you
drive new market offering and business practices.
Talent, how do you acquire and retain talent,
again an intangible, it is something not easily
measured and quantified but really important
to improve productivity. If you are wondering
where environment is, it is at the bottom
of the list and it falls under, it’s number
ten, and it is called Improved Corporate Environmental
Sustainability and Social Responsibility.
I think the way that that question is framed
and the fact that it’s a separate add on,
it’s thought of in terms of responsibility
and not in terms of something that actually
advances every single one of those things.
In the growth, efficiency, innovation and
talent department. It’s a measure, a sort
of indication, of where we are and it’s
where things are changing. The CEOs and the
companies that are visionary are seeing the
connection and the through line through all
those categories and not seeing it as a stand-alone.
Really, this is what the book is meant to
sort of help people with. It is designed not
for, as I say, just the Chief Sustainability
Officer or the CEO, and it is not meant to
be read from cover to cover. But it is meant
to be a really practical guide that a CEO
could hand to somebody that is the Chief Information
Officer, the Chief Technology Officer, the
head of R and D or the supply chain and say
“Hey, check out this. Have we tried these
different things? Have we looked at these
different plays, they seem to be paying off
for other people. Would this work?” And
to be very clear, Dan and I, in this book,
are very adamant. If this is going to work
for you you need to apply the same sort of
business tough approach that you would for
any other business decision making issue and
not every play that we talk about in the book
is going to pay off for every company. But
for the companies that do, apply the lens
and the kind of principles we sort of guarantee
that you will find ways that it pays off for
your business. And you will see that these
are Chapters 8-17. I pulled them out because
it sort of gives you a sense of the fact that
we wrote for these different audiences and
tried to use, tried to start from the prospective
of what is it that somebody in logistics is
really going to be caring about and how could
green actually help with what they are doing.
As an extension, just one last word about
sort of where we both think this is going
and why Dan and I wanted to get this book
out there. To sort of accelerate the trends
that we think are under way, where Green is
no longer seen as separate thing. Where it
is pivotal to long term business success and
it’s integrated with business activities
across value chains, it’s a top innovation
driver, and you see there are lots and lots
of surveys that supports this is the megatrend.
We want to just move it a little faster given
what’s actually happening with global environmental
trends. One final word before I talk about
some of the examples from the book, one of
the things that I have been thinking about
a lot recently is vocabulary and how we talk
about these issues. The word "environment"
I think has a connotation, built-in connotation,
that make people think of polar bears and
spotted owls and all sorts of mega-charismatic
species and not about something that we actually
connect to. And the business context , again
it's seen as, often times, it activates a
way of thinking about corporate responsibility,
stewardship, values and so forth. You see
these kinds of statements in annual reports
and in our websites. We care about the environment
so it is something separate from us. We have
a responsibility to the environment, to the
planet, this is our environmental strategy,
as apart from our business strategy. We want
to generate win/win outcomes for the business
and the planet so they are two different things.
It struck me a couple of weeks ago that maybe
we ought to just replace the word environment
in a lot of those conversations with the word
"long-term". And if you do that, it actually
ends up really getting to the basic logic
of what this is all about. It’s about businesses
caring about their long-term success and competitiveness.
The responsibility to their long-term, and
to the share holders in the long-term. It's
their long-term strategy and they want to
generate win/wins not just for, when they
say the business, but what they often times
means quarterly profits. They also want to
generate win/wins for the short term profits
and for the long term. So let me just focus
on the rest of the time, give you some examples
from the book of some of the plays that are
paying off for companies and where we talk
about a lot more in the Playbook. And on the
first and closest to home is the office environment
and how is affects virtually every company.
And a great place to start is paper and printing.
We have all probably been to the printer,
shared printers and seen a ton of paper that
has just been left there by other people and
not been picked up or we have forgotten to
pick something up ourselves at the printer.
There is Xerox research that says that 40
percent of printouts are discarded within
24 hours. We don’t need, most every single
company whether its small or large can actually
get rid of a lot of paper and save a lot of
money in the process. Some of the research
we uncovered pointed to savings of about $1250
per employee per year with a return on investment
of 300% through just really simple measures,
like making double sided printings standard
and with helping users with software that
actually makes it easier for them to make
better choices. Lockheed-Martin , a big defense
contractor, saves ¼ million dollars every
year by shifting a manual they used to hand
out to all employees that seems kind of mindless
by saying “Here read this.” Which would
just sit on a lot of desks, they put it online
and that is saving them ¼ of a million dollars
a year. Barclays Capital in the UK actually
requires the use of a swipe card to go pick
up your print jobs and that is saving about
½ a million dollars a years. And GE estimates
that it is saving, has saved about 1.6 billion
over the last decade by shifting a lot of
things to digital. I am proud to say that
in writing the Green to Gold Playbook I didn’t
print, well, I didn’t actually have a printer
that was working, I did everything online.
We used Wikis , we used Google docs, we used
all sorts of collaborative techniques and
.pdf viewers and the only paper was actually
when the publisher sent me single-sided versions
of the manuscript, which ended up, this was
the last day before we sent it off to the
publisher. There is a ton of things that can
be done in the office environment. We go through
a whole handful from electricity use, paper,
trash, water, e-waste, travel, food and these
are things that Google is operating on all
cylinders in this regard too. A big theme
that we talk about, not just in the context
of office environments, but also in virtually
every part of the book is engaging the talent
and the ideas of people like you that are
just on the frontlines and know what the problems
are and can figure out creatively what the
solutions are. For instance, one great example
of this that I love from Yale University they've
got thirteen dormitories. They created a competition
and the reward was $300 of pizza. That was
the investment. And that generated tons of
ideas which ultimately lead to a million dollars
in energy savings for Yale just out of the
$300 investment. Similarly at WalMart they
went through, several years ago, they started
involving people in what they called a Personal
Sustainability Pledge or Project, now they
call it My Sustainability Pledge. And they
put a lot of employees through a training
where they got to think about “What does
sustainability mean to me? How can I make
a difference in my personal life and my job
that is going to benefit me and benefit the
business?” And one guy was sitting in a
break room and he realized the lights in the
vending machine were on in a very well lit
room, this is not the actual room, but he
basically got this idea that this was serious
waste and it bubbled up to Corporate. WalMart
is saving a million dollars a year just by
turning off the light bulbs in its vending
machines. It’s just one of those simple
ideas that when you start giving people and
empowering people with the concepts and give
them some examples, the creativity they come
up with is just amazing. Closer to home for
all of you in the area of information technology,
one of the things that is making a big difference
and really paying off for a lot of companies
is using video conferencing and remote collaboration
and telecommuting to really drive a lot of
cost savings and actually make employees a
lot happier. How many of you either telecommute
at any point like one day a week now or how
many of you currently do? And how many of
you would like to that don't already? So for
those of you that do, you probably have, you
can probably speak of some of the benefits
that are there. But the research really bears
out that what it does is help companies really
cut real estate costs in a huge way, about
twenty five percent of IBM staff telecommute
regularly and that program saved the company
fifty million dollars. And there are a lot
of studies that show that there is a boost
in productivity and that people actually work.
I can attest to this, too, because I telecommute.
You actually work more hours in part because
you are not stuck in traffic and you are not
dealing with the hassles and vagaries of weather
and everything else. This can really help
with retention because there are a lot of
studies that this makes people happier. In
the McKessen Corporation which is in the Health
Care Sector, reports that the group that it
has the highest job satisfaction in it’s
whole company are the thousand nurses that
they have working from home. On a related
note, video conferencing is huge and collaboration
tools and I can just point out how much I
love Google+ and I am one of early early adopters
and one of the evangelists of the technology.
But here you have Google+ hangouts which allows
up to ten people to communicate really quickly
at a time. And this kind of innovation is
really brining down the cost and making it
affordable for virtually anybody to take advantage
of these kinds of technologies and reduce
a lot of travel as well which is really costly
for companies. And a huge source of carbon
emissions as well which when companies start
counting up their carbon emissions, travel
for a lot of companies is big. So this helps
on multiple fronts. And then you have solutions
like Cisco Telepresence which are also really
coming down considerably in cost and so the
payback is fast. Not just because of the prices
are coming down but because of the massive
amount of savings for travel reduction are
often times paying for the equipment and the
investment in like fifteen months or less.
Moving into the area of buildings which is
an area we spend a whole chapter on, have
a lot of checklists. It used to be that a
lot of great opportunities in Greening buildings
and in saving money were untapped because
people just have the perception that it costs
a lot more, lack of awareness about the best
practice and opportunities. That is really
changing as companies exchange their success
stories the costs are dramatically coming
down. The upfront cost premium for a commercial
Green building today is only about two percent
compared to a traditional building. And the
time to recoup the initial investment has
dropped down to an average of three to four
years. The return on investment over a twenty
year period on a Green building now stands
at four to six times the upfront costs. And
Green building are not only sort of paying
back for themselves and generating a lot of
operational saving and reduced energy bills
and retirement and everything else. But they
are also commanding rent premiums of about
$11.33 more per square foot for LEED certified,
which is one of the highest environmental
rating system that people have over traditional
buildings. They also have higher resale rates,
they are selling for $171 more per square
foot over, LEED building are, over the traditional
counterparts. One of my favorite examples
of not a Green building, it didn’t start
that way, but has been retrofit to become
one is the Empire State Building. I actually
took this from my apartment so it is not the
clearest picture but one of the things I love
about the building is that they have transformed
the idea of what lights at night look like
and just by lighting up with LED lights at
the very top of the building they have created
this iconic thing that everybody loves in
New York City. Of course it changes and people
go on the website and look at what the different
colors mean, but what they did recently is
invest twenty million dollars in retrofits
to try to make the whole building much more
energy efficient. They are getting a payback
in three years for that and they are expecting
4.4 million dollars for annual savings by
cutting energy like thirty eight percent just
by that initial investment. You know there
are so many areas again that we cover in the
Playbook, from plugging holes literally in
doors and windows, better insulation, setting
water temperature lower, putting air conditioning
and heating at rational levels. I just went
to a luxury hotel recently and got put up
there and it was another one of those experiences
where you turn on the tap of hot water and
you almost burn yourself because it is so
hot. And then you walk into the hallways and
it is like fifty degrees [chuckles] like the
Arctic. That’s not luxury to me and it is
just a huge amount of waste for the company
that they are doing stuff like that. So we
have a lot of examples and checklists in the
book for things like that. Lighting is one
of the big areas where, one of the first areas
that we encourage people to focus on. It consumes
about thirty five percent of electricity in
US commercial buildings. And the EPA says
that we are wasting about fifty percent of
the energy associated with lighting because
of inefficient design and poor maintenance
and inappropriate use. Huge payback in this
area and one of the, I pulled this up too
since I was thinking about the incandescent
light bulbs which are often joked by engineers
as being little heat engines that emit a little
bit of light. Because they emit so much heat
that someone invented a product around them
[chuckles] back in the seventies, an Easy
Bake Oven. But the sort of newer forms of
lighting drive down a lot of bills and they
also boost productivity. And one of the things
that was staggering that I learned in the
context of this book that a lot of folks are
saying that better lighting boost productivity
and makes people happier at work. So the numbers
again are controversial because how do you
measure that, how much to put a price on that.
But one of the things that one of the researchers
did was they calculated at even a one percent
productivity bump from lighting . You think
about how much companies spend on employees
and salaries, if you boost productivity by
just one percentage, sort of an estimate that
can actually offset in many cases companies
lighting bill for the entire, energy bill
for the entire year. That can make a big difference.
Another area we focus on is roofs, painting
a roof white is a really simple measure; it
deflects a lot of heat. Green buildings are
becoming a more popular for similar reasons.
All of this changes the ambient temperature;
it reduces the load on the AC and the heating
within actual companies, or building. Con
Edison here in New York actually installed
both of these forms in its corporate head
quarters recently reducing the summer heat
gains by sixty seven percent, the white roof
is. And the Green roof is cutting summer heat
by eighty four percent, and winter heating
losses by thirty seven percent. So huge gains
in the building area.
Going back to your realm of information technology,
this is an area where the role of IT professionals,
the Chief Information Officers, is becoming
big and I think it’s going to become absolutely
huge and indispensable for companies that
really want to seize Eco Advantage . And it
is obviously big for just about every company
because every company uses IT in one way or
another. But for companies that actually are
built around IT like Google, this is a huge
area of both impact and opportunity. First
of all most companies spent a lot of money
on energy because of IT and when you get more
efficient about it you can save a huge amount
of money as a result. IBM says that its clients
as it helps get more efficient in this area,
get fifteen to seventy percent reduction in
operating costs through IT efficiency initiatives
and full payback in most cases in one to two
years. And these again are fairly simple measures
and IBM itself actually saved forty nine million,
or avoided forty nine million dollars in costs
in building a whole new data center because
it did some efficiency measures to make one
of its data centers hugely more efficient
and upped the capacity of that data center
by eight times. So it avoided having to build
a whole new building, forty nine million dollars
saved from a one million dollar investment
in a Green overhaul of that data center. Second
of all the reason why IT is such a big area
is because companies are going to face increasing
pressure in this area to address the rising
impacts associated with IT. Especially in
the area of Greenhouse Gas Emissions associated
with energy use at their data centers but
all sorts of the devices that we carry around
and plug in and of toxics associated with
electronic waves. In fact McKinsey , the consulting
firm, predicts that by 2020 the biggest source
of Greenhouse Gas Emissions worldwide could
come from information and communications technologies
and products. And of course we have all heard
about E-waste and toxic issues being a really
big problem. And then finally and I think
most interestingly there is potential for
the IT industry and IT professionals to really
transform a lot of processes and be net solutions
drivers. So yes, you have all those impacts
but there is potential to actually move the
industry in a way that solves some many sustainability
problems that its own impacts are offset by
all those contributions. And you see a lot
of companies getting into the consulting space
and sustainability software space, huge explosions
of offerings that try to help companies deal
with the huge amount of analytics that people
are now trying to grapple with all the sustainability
metrics to try to make their company more
efficient, make their supply chains more efficient,
track what’s happening in Indonesia and
China with one of their suppliers. Lots of
complexity in terms of information that IT
professionals are seizing or jumping on the
band wagon to just try to solve [pause].
We talk about a lot of different areas in
the book in IT that people can make a difference
on a lot of the end user environment efficiency
and so forth. But one of the biggest areas
is data centers obviously and I think most
of you are probably very familiar with this
issue and you know that Google is one of the
world leaders in this area so I am not going
to spend too much time on this but just a
couple of issues to mention when it comes
to data centers cause it is so important.
You know there is two key issues when it comes
to data centers from an environmental and
energy standpoint. First off the energy and
the impacts form the equipment itself and
second of all the energy and impacts from
the building and the structures that actually
house them. All the cooling and heating and
lighting associated with that. Right now according
to the EPA and Department of Energy of the
United Stated, data centers represent about
1.5 percent of all the energy that is consumed
in the United States. And that figure is likely
to double in the next five years. Cooling
is a big area where it adds up for companies,
where it costs a lot of money. About ten years
ago about seventeen cents per dollar spent
on a new server went towards power and cooling
and today it’s up to forty eight cents.
If that number doesn’t change, according
to one estimate, it could go up to seventy
eight cents. So companies are doing a lot
to change this and Google is one of the pioneers
here as I mentioned and really helping to
accelerate the spread of those best practices
and what we call "next" practices, emerging
practices in this area. One of the companies
that is doing some really interesting things
in this space is Yahoo. The reason I bring
them up is they built this data center in
New York that actually draws a lot of free,
literally free cooling that it doesn’t have
to pay for it from the outside air and they
were inspired to invent this from looking
at how chicken coops actually cool naturally.
But again really some of the most exciting
stuff in this area has to do with the potential
for IT to drive sustainability problem solving
at the company level, at the regional level,
the country level and really at the global
level. And I think Google Earth Engine, which
was just announced recently in Cancun at the
Climate Negotiations last December is really
one of the most stunning examples of this.
I love this picture, it is of the Chief of
an Amazonian tribe called the Surui and they
are using Earth Engine to help measure forest
carbon in their area. But this is an incredibly
powerful and important monitoring platform
that is going to be an invaluable tool in
curbing deforestation around the world. And
it was launched by .org so a lot of you may
be wondering why I am mentioning this in sort
of a business focused presentation, but again
going back to the brand impacts. First of
all, I think this actually is one of the products
that Google comes out with that is associated
with this brand that really does drive a lot
of people to feel great about the brand of
Google and it’s really invaluable in that
sense. But it’s also, as they say, sort
of indicative of a solution to many sort of
emerging needs and problems out there where
IT can be a solution.
Very quickly in the manufacturing space the
idea of Green being sort of taking lean manufacturing
to new heights, putting lean on steroids.
It’s about sort of routing out waste in
all forms and sort of identifying waste that
you might not otherwise see and one of the
secret weapons for anybody in Green manufacturing,
sort of like the pizza party at Yale, is to
tap into the talent and the expertise of line
employees. One of the things that General
Electric does is they have these treasure
hunts that have been replicated and shared
with a lot of other companies that are doing
similar things now. And these are pictures
from a three day treasure hunt in Wisconsin
where they set a goal and they call it the
Hunt for Carbon or something. The idea is
that carbon is a symptom of waste and so they
are going to go hunt for carbon to try to
find at least seven hundred thousand dollars
in energy savings. What then team did is they
went on a weekend when normally things are
shut down and they tried to look at all the
things that were sort of spinning around,
the lights that were on in the bathrooms or
wherever, ventilation issues and tried to
get a sense of where there is waste. They
came up with three million dollars in savings
just in a three day treasure hunt. Miller
Coors is an example of a company that has
actually gone and taken some of its plants,
as GM has and a lot of other companies have,
to zero waste. They were generating 1.6 million
in pounds of trash in 2007. Some of their
folks got together and said we want to create
a goal of within five years getting to zero
waste, they did it in two. Another company
that makes vacuum cleaners, that you may own,
Bissell, uses a lot of the input to its products
to make new products and just keeps recycling
stuff and recycling and they call it, it’s
closed loop manufacturing. It’s an idea
inspired by nature, where nature doesn’t
waste anything it just keeps recycling stuff
over and over again and using those inputs.
In the area of logistics and transportations;
planes, trains, automobiles and trucks, you
have a lot of folks who have been slow adopters
to this because they have to worry about getting
things precisely where they ought to be, exactly
when they ought to be in the right shape.
So many thing and variables that could go
wrong, so for a lot of logistics professional
supply chain leaders the idea of adding Green
has been “I can’t deal with this, we have
so many things on our plates already.” The
companies that have including FedEx and Staples
and UPS and WalMart and so many other companies
that have accomplished logistics operations
have found enormous savings here. And one
of the simple measures that a lot of companies
that take are with their trucks they take
and put these auxiliary power units on so
that the trucks don’t have to idle. Because
truckers driving around twenty four hours
they have got to actually sleep, so usually
what they would happen is they keep the engine
running to keep the air conditioning on and
keep the heating on in the summer and winter
time. These auxiliary power units can save
up to twenty gallons a day for a truck which
really you can imagine adds up to huge savings
over time. A lot of companies are now getting
into hybrid trucks, big upfront investment
but a huge payoff in the form of savings.
Fuel, forty percent better mileage, and also
maintenance costs tend to be less for all
the companies that investing in this stuff.
One of the examples that I love from logistics
is from Boeing. They actually were inspired
by the sort of biomechanics of dragonflies
and bats. They ended up putting these winglets
on a lot of the planes that have cut fuel
use in the planes that use them by three percent,
which may not sound like a lot and that’s
the whole idea with sustainability. These
little things that when you start adding them
up it’s like compound interest, the numbers
can be astounding when you start creating
these little innovations that can lead to
big changes.
Another big area is packaging. It took this
picture; it is probably one of the most egregious
examples. But there have been so many where
I get this box where something could have
just mailed the box, but a sticker on the
box. What that leads to is a lot of trucks
that are could be filled much more efficiently,
a lot of wasted gas, a lot of wasted fuel
in airplanes and so forth. And a lot of wasted
packaging that the consumer, the customers,
end up having to deal with which is a drag.
Let me move now and sort of wrap up in talking
about product innovations in some of the areas
where companies are actually boosting revenues
because they are innovating a lot of products.
Start with a couple of examples of pioneers
in this area that are pretty well known. One
is ZipCar, a lot of you may not think of ZipCar
as a Green player or Green company. I don’t
think they sort of started that way either.
But the idea was that they basically have
done is taken a product and turned it into
a service. And in the process of doing that
they have taken for every car that they have
they have taken fifteen and twenty cars off
the road and they are now boasting about that
in terms of their Green credentials, rightly
so. But this concept of actually going from
product to service is a really important one,
driving a lot of innovation. Similarly Interface
Carpet Company, many of you may have heard
of it, if you haven’t there is a remarkable
man Ray Anderson who is CEO and founder of
Interface Carpet Company. He kind of got religion
many years ago when he read Paul Hawkins book
the Ecology of Commerce. He was running this
industrial carpet company that was generating
enormous amounts toxic waste and so forth.
And he was so inspired by the concepts there
that he decided to really undertake a radical
vision for his company and try to be a net
zero, have net zero impact by the year 2020.
That galvanized the company much like the
brewing company that I mentioned earlier.
That people are really excited about that
vision, the retention has been great, the
branding has been fantastic and they came
up with this innovation that many of you may
have seen. Flor Carpets where you can actually
buy carpet tiles and that way you can, first
of all, design a carpet to look exactly the
way you want it, which is pretty cool and
is a new benefit for companies. But is also
allows you to actually reduce the costs of
maintenance because you can recarpet very
heavily trafficked areas and not have to buy
a whole other carpet and of course reduce
a huge amount of waste too. There is a company
called, in the newer entrepreneurial space,
Active Ion, that just last year developed
something called the Ionator EXP. That Fortune
said was one of the top ten destructive technologies
in the world, and it actually turns tap water
into a chemical free cleaning agent that kills
almost 100 percent of germs. And there is
a lot of demand for hospitals and businesses
for these kinds of cleaning solutions. Even
Valvoline is getting into the act with recycled
motor oil. This is a really interesting example
from a company called StoCoat in Vermont that
was inspired by the lotus flower which in
Asian culture symbolizes purity because of
its ability to remain clean while growing
in a dirty environment. And what they managed
to do was replicate the surface microstructure
of the lotus plant [clears throat] leaf in
paint so that you never have to wash your
buildings, the dirt just sort of washes off.
A company named AkzoNobel , you may know that
does paints and performance coatings and specialized
chemicals in Europe now is focused on EcoPremium
solutions sort of like GE’s EcoMagination
solutions. And that’s generating a huge
amount of profit for the company higher margins
for these products. They were inspired by
the way that a lot of marine mammals move
through water in a very sleek way and they
came up with this coating that allows ships
to actually move through the water a lot faster,
more efficiently, safe the customer money
and they are getting a huge boost in profits
from that. Another really interesting example
in Calera, they have actually flipped the
idea of cement on its head. They actually
were inspired by coral reefs and the way the
marine organisms actually develop their own
shells and grown within a marine environment.
So they developed a process where they take
carbon dioxide out of industrial processes
and use that waste to actually make cement.
And what is most interesting I think about
the businesses model is that it doesn’t
go out selling cement; it relies on charging
the polluters to actually have the service
of taking carbon dioxide and sequestering
the carbon dioxide. So free cement but carbon
negative cement which in an industry like
cement is huge because it is such a big contributor
to carbon emissions.
I just want to end with the statement that
a lot of people ask me “Is the Green stuff
a fad?” and I have felt after working on
this stuff for seventeen years now, I have
felt for seventeen years that it is not only
not a fad it is something that is going to
be something so powerfully part of everything
that we think about and do. Maybe not in our
lifetimes but fairly soon and one of the reasons
for that is that the fundamental drivers that
are driving all this pressure from activists,
from investors, from share holders, from customers,
from NGOs, all this pressure is routed in
some realities about what’s going on with
our natural world and with our natural ecosystems.
And I took this picture recently in Bahia,
a few weeks ago in Brazil. This tree is kind
of overtaking this natural structure that
we had built and I was thinking how, in fact,
you know we tend to think about ecosystems
again as this other thing, but in fact these
are these remarkable natural biological infrastructures
that have been built through R and D for four
and one half billion years on this planet
that do pretty amazing things. Certainly when
you stop and think about it, rain falls on
a virgin forest; it’s healthy and out comes
water that we can all drink, that purifies
our water. The Amazon is known as the lungs
of the planet cause it breathes twenty percent
of the oxygen that we breathe on this planet.
You have mangroves off the coast on Indonesia
that not only are protecting when they are
healthy, protecting people against Katrina-like
events or tsunamis but there are also nursing
ninety percent of the fish. So they are serving
as the nurseries for that and they are a huge
amount of the solution for sequestering carbon
in our atmosphere. We have all this systems
that sort of work behind our backs and we
all take for granted and the reality though
is that a lot of this has been free for us
until recently and what I think companies
are just beginning to understand is that nature
in a sense is going to start charging for
all that stuff. And back in 1997 when a bunch
of economists did an estimate of if we had
to pay for all of this stuff, what is it that
nature is giving us for free? And then came
up with the figure of thirty three trillion
dollars annually of free goods and services
that we get. That’s double, at the time,
double the output of all the world’s economies
combined. And that number has been recently
updated and is being updated and could be
double at this point. When you think about
what it would cost us to build that infrastructure
that nature has already got around, the answer
is usually it would cost us a lot more. We
saw this in New York City, here in the New
York City Watershed for years, for decades
we have always talked about New York having
the finest water in the world. You go to a
restaurant and say “I’ll take New Yorks’
finest!” Well several years ago, about fifteen
years ago, the water started degrading in
quality and the EPA basically came and said
New York City you are going to have to build
an eight billion dollar water treatment plant
to safeguard people from this water that is
unhealthy to drink. And some genius had the
idea that in fact nature was doing this for
a long time by itself and maybe we ought to
restore and fix the natural infrastructure
that was already there rather than build this
eight billion dollar plant. So for a fraction
of the cost, New York City issued a bond issue,
they changed land rights, they paid farmers,
educated farmers to do different practices.
And instead of having to build a plant that
would actually have millions of dollars of
annual upkeep cost and have the upfront investment,
for a small fraction of that we ended up restoring
the natural info structure and now we still
have clean water. This kind of story is being
repeated around the world. But you know recently
what I am excited about is that there are
big companies and institutions, Price Waterhouse,
teamed up with Georges Bach and the UN and
several other actors to create something called
the Economics of Ecosystems and Biodiversity
Assessment recently. And one of the things
that they concluded is the ecosystem threats
are going to eclipse climate change in economic
impacts but there are still off the CEO and
valuations radar screen. They estimated that
the current costs that we are doing, in terms
of global environmental damage, is about six
and one half trillion dollars in 2008, eleven
percent of GDP. It’s estimated to be twenty
eight trillion on 2050 and at three thousand
public companies cause one third of the damage.
And if those big companies don’t think that
folks are going to actually put pressure on
them to start accounting for that damage that
so far has been external, as we call these
externalities in economics. It’s an easy
way of saying it sort of doesn’t matter
at the moment but in fact people are paying
the cost indirectly. We are all paying the
costs and companies are eventually going to
start paying the costs much more directly.
What this all means is that there is going
to be more demands for transparency, more
ratings systems like we see, we see countless
explosion of surveys like Corporate Responsibility
Magazine. We are going to see them rating
companies based on all sorts of different
criteria. We see more demands for radical
transparencies, Patagonia has been a pioneer
doing it’s Footprint Chronicles and sort
of allowing consumers to sort of look at where
a particular object that they bought was manufactured
and follow the train all across the supply
chain. WalMart is actually starting to do
this with barcodes on fish and other products.
You see companies like WalMart that are demanding
for all of their suppliers, their billions
of dollars worth of suppliers, for answers
about how they are doing, what their sustainability
performance is because they realize that it
is all connected. More effort to try to make
it easier for the consumer. This is not necessarily
the answer but the Carbon Trust has a label
that it has worked on in the UK to sort of
work with Tesco to actually put a carbon footprint
label on every product so that companies,
so that consumers can differentiate . And
it also means that there is going to be more
regulation and hopefully it’s smart regulation
that actually creates incentives and frameworks
and gives private sector the flexibility to
innovate and come up with the right answers
at the right costs and doesn’t just sort
of command and control like we have seen in
the past. But companies need to prepare for
more regulations. And there is going to be
more global competition in this area. We have
seen in the areas of wind and solar and a
lot of other high tech, clean tech areas where
the US was the catalyst and was the original
innovator. A lot of those industries are becoming
the global sort of leaders are in other countries.
That is just going to keep being an issue
as we move forward. Why am I optimistic at
the end of the day, people ask me if I am
optimistic or pessimistic about this sort
of state of affairs here and are companies
doing enough? First of all, I am incredibly
optimistic because I have seen countless examples
including Google of companies that have really
been visionary in creating things that nobody
could have even imagined in terms of solutions
several years ago. But when you compare it
to the scale of the issues that are causing
are these fundamental drivers, it’s nowhere
near. The gap is just unfathomable. And so
what we need and what the companies are sort
of "next practice" in this area, are thinking
like Albert Einstein. We can’t solve problems
using the same kind of thinking we have when
we created them. We need totally new frameworks
and fresh thinking. And so what I answer,
I am optimistic when I meet people like you
and companies like Google and I am sort of
reminded in a situation like this of the scene
in 'Airplane' where Leslie Nielsen keeps coming
into cockpit as the plane is coming down and
he says “I just want to let you all know
we are all counting on you!” That’s sort
of the way I feel about all of you and I thank
you for your time today and I thank you in
advance for all the great stuff you are going
to do for the future! Thanks. [clears throat]
[ applause ]
Let me add just one other quick word if I
could, for those of you that are interested
in keeping up with what properties are doing
and the sort of latest trends in Corporate
sustainability, we published a free briefing
every Monday morning. This is a no nonsense,
no advertising briefing that highlights a
lot of the most notable plays that companies
are doing and government regulation and market
technology trends and everything else. You
can sign up for it on our website ecoforum.com.
In the upper left you will see that sign up
for free CF weekly briefing and if you want
to keep in touch with me you can email me
anytime. I look forward to meeting you guys
afterwards and follow me on Twitter.